let's go next to oh there's some
interesting folks here
some interesting folks let's go to i'm
going to pronounce it correctly this
time
nisha from michigan did i get it right
nisha
yes david you got it right thank you
what's going on
um not that much um i actually
um did talk to uh my friend um that i
talked to you about
um i guess the last time that i was on
yeah it was like a pretty it was like a
trumpist but not a super crazy one is
that right
yeah she's well she's definitely not a
trumpist or anything like that
um she just just doesn't really like um
she doesn't really trust um the uh
you know the the vaccine and whatnot oh
it was the vaccine okay all right fair
enough okay yes
vaccine got it we kind of had a bit of a
falling out
really am i responsible for it
no no no you're not um because
i told her that um a friend of mine and
another friend of mine and her mother
they were fully vaccinated and i was
actually able
to let them see um my child right
and once uh i think once i told her that
i think she kind of got very defensive
and then she asked me why did i
get the vaccine because now i'm fully
vaccinated
right so i pretty much of course had to
go and tell like
the reason why i got my vaccination was
because
to protect my daughter and whatnot and
also
my husband also got the same thing as
well yep so
i tried to not get into a debate
with her because she was asking me so
many questions and then she was
bombarding me with all this stuff and
she was even telling me
of course with her um whatever type of
resources she
had and i was like well where's your
well where's your proof
and what where's your proof and whatnot
it was like well i don't know where'd
you get your stuff i
read my stuff so
right i i just couldn't really oh man
and then i had to go and ask my husband
to pretty much help me out because she
kept on saying that um
the vaccine was pretty much done in like
in a matter of months
and i pretty much had to go and tell
like it wasn't really in a matter of
months
it pretty much took uh over a decade
right yeah i think my approach to when
people say that is
you know sequencing the virus is a
matter of a few hours
what the point here with these mrna
vaccines is the underlying technology
and that's been researched for more than
a decade
sequencing the virus is child's play and
it can be done in just a matter of hours
but that that
this is a different type of vaccine and
so just applying that kind of statement
doesn't really make sense because the
underlying technology's been in
development for so long
all right and because i think my husband
has said that
um i think it's i think they started
doing it i think back in 2003
so pretty much uh almost i guess close
to two decades i i i
but nisha so are you guys not no longer
speaking because of the vaccine
differences of opinion uh pretty much
his differences of opinion she
she of course told me that her sister
was of course getting the vaccine and
her mother was
two yeah and she also she was
infected with covid um i think
maybe maybe three weeks ago so she
finally of course got out of it
yeah and i was pretty much thinking like
don't you think that would at least
gotten a reason well
then a reason for you to at least take
the vaccine just so you don't get sick
anymore
right because i kind of had some type of
some type of
epiphany like if you keep on getting
sick from the same
virus over and over again it might i
don't know
i could be wrong that it might damage
you
in some type of way to where you can't
really recover from it well once you
recover you're protected from that
strain for some period of time but it's
not as robust protection as from
uh as from getting vaccinated yeah well
listen
um hopefully the the relationship can be
uh reconvened and rehabilitated and i
really appreciate you giving me the
update nisha
okay all right thanks very much
there is nisha from michigan with an
update there